Toula card gesture Ronnie lipstick
announces that today he's going to work
some muscles of a Chevrolet muscle car
and Chevy's muscle cars of course the
Camaro it's been in production for over
50 years now it's time for the car maker
to roll out the anniversary model and
this is it Ronnie can't wait to see how
it handles on the street so off he goes
the Camaro was first presented in 1966
and hits showroom floors in 1967 now the
50th anniversary edition is the sixth
generation to carry on the traditions of
design and performance that Camaro has
stood for right from the start but is it
still the muscle car at once was or
closer to a run-of-the-mill European
sports car
[Music]
they come out with it Ronnie knows this
Camaros kept the familiar American
engine configuration of v8 to be precise
a 6.2 liter he doesn't even want to get
started on the fuel consumption but
focuses instead on the sound it makes
when he accelerates
the new Camaro is shorter slimmer and
lighter than its predecessor the VA puts
out 333 kilowatts and lay some maximum
617 Newton meters of torque on the
asphalt that carries it from 0 to 100
km/h in 4.6 seconds
he says performance like that is enough
to make any connoisseurs mouth water
average fuel consumption is rated at
twelve point eight liters per 100
kilometers but Rani somewhat sporty
driving pushed it closer to 15 liters
really likes the 6-speed manual
transmission he never would have thought
you could shift so easily and precisely
on such a gigantic engine transmission
and engine together all but guaranteed
dynamic handling guarantees and dynamics
waffle
the Fallen Ronnie rates the performances
comparatively good a magnetic ride
suspension adapts the damping system to
the road conditions automatically a bit
unusual for muscle cars with their
typically squishy leaf springs that just
fascinates him all the more performance
isn't the only plus for the new
Chevrolet Camaro the sixth generation is
also quite a looker the emblems and
badging for the anniversary edition are
only minor details this Camaro looks
sleeker and more angular than its
predecessor the rounded contours have
disappeared almost completely
[Music]
inside as well Chevrolet has obviously
done its homework and left out the
slapdash cheap-looking materials typical
of many other American cars the
workmanship here is high-quality
[Music]
[Applause]
Rahmi feels almost like he's sitting
inside a mailbox it's as if he's looking
through three visor slits or four but he
doesn't count the rear windshield since
he can't see anything through it anyway
he describes the all-round visibility as
miserable he doesn't mean to say he
can't see anything at all
but he's glad to have a rear vision
camera to help him back into parking
spaces
a Camaro with its v8 engine list for a
good forty five thousand nine hundred
euros a handsome price for this car it
offers good performance and the interior
comfort typical of American cars that
includes a state-of-the-art
entertainment system and of course the
unmistakable Camaro look Ronnie would
wholeheartedly recommend it and if that
v8 guzzles too much fuel there's always
the choice of a 2-liter turbocharged
engine